[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT FEINBERG: Hi, everyone.
My name is Scott Feinberg.
I'm a customer
engineer with Google.
Before I joined Google
about 10 months ago,
I worked at "The New York
Times" on "The New York Times"
cooking app.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
So today we're going to be
talking about a product that's
been around for a little while
now renamed, as of this week,
to Cloud Build.
So Cloud Build is Google's--
think of it like a pay-as-you-go
serverless platform for CI/CD.
So if you've used things like
Jenkins, Drone, CircleCI,
TravisCI, blank
name followed by CI,
you kind of know how
these sort of things work.
Google's approach is a
little bit different.
You don't pay for
static hardware
to hold your test runners
and all that stuff.
There's no slaves.
You just upload it.
We run it for you as
a Docker container
and then spit out
the results for you.
So it's an integrated experience
into the rest of Google Cloud,
and it works really well.
And what we're going to do today
is we're going to walk through
step-by-step--
I didn't realize there were
animations on that page--
step-by-step on sort
of how to take an app
and add Cloud Build
to it and adding that
CI/CD functionality to your app.
So Cloud Build is not an
answer to every problem
when it comes to CI/CD.
If you're looking for
something more advanced
with really expressive
ways of deploying,
you probably need
something more robust,
like Spinnaker, which
is an open source
project that Google and Netflix
launched a few years ago.
But Cloud Build solves
a lot of problems.
And you can extend
it as far as you
want to because every build
step is just a Docker container.
So we're going to switch
over to the live screen.
Boom.
Fantastic.
So we're going to take an app.
So I currently have
an app running on GKE.
This is a sample
app that Pivotal
has called "The Pet Clinic."
So if you happen
to have any pets,
this is what your vet might use.
I'm waiting for it to load.
But essentially, it's running
on a GKE in containers.
And we're going to walk
through how to actually add
Cloud Build to it.
And make sure the internet's
actually connected.
Yeah, cool.
So the app's just slow.
Fantastic.
But it is running.
It's in Container Builder.
Here's my cluster.
We have a couple of
different processes
that we'll be deploying out to.
So this is the web process.
If you've used GKE before,
this should all look familiar,
how you actually access it.
So there's a load
balancer, as you can see.
And we're going to
deploy out to it.
So we're going to do
this all in Cloud Shell.
So Cloud Shell is basically
just a hosted development
environment that already has all
of your permissions and stuff
baked into it.
Two-Factor off is important.
I'm going to just let
that load for a second.
How many people here have
used Cloud Build before?
So a few people?
Who have used
Cloud Shell before?
Yeah?
It's pretty cool.
I like it.
So we're going to open up
The Pet Clinic app, so pretty
straightforward.
Most of what we'll be looking
at will be in the CLI here.
Everyone can see in the
back what I'm typing?
Pretty much?
Cool.
So we're going to check out
the beginning of our project.
Because I don't trust myself to
actually type out all the code,
you'll see that I have
branches for all the code.
So as much as this
looks like live coding,
I've written it before.
So here we have sort of
just a very basic Java
app, looks very familiar.
But this is just an MP app.
We don't have a
Docker file in it yet.
There's no Cloud Build.
This would just run.
So this is packaged with Maven.
So that'll actually run
the tests, build the JAR,
which will actually run
in the Docker container.
So for our first step, we're
going to check out the Docker
file that we'll use for this.
So you see here, we have a
two-step process, very simple.
We're going to
run Maven package.
So this runs the
test, builds the JAR.
And in the second
step, we copy the Jar
we generated in the first step.
And that's the only thing
running in that Docker file.
So just make sure that that
image is as thin as possible
so that we don't have to
actually deploy Maven to prod
and all the other build
aspects of the pipeline.
So initially, so that's
the Docker container.
If I ran Docker Build,
which I won't because it
takes a little while,
that would build,
and we would have a Docker
container that we could run.
So the first step to
actually add Cloud Build
is to add a cloudbuild.YAML.
So it's very straightforward.
I'm going to refresh.
And there it is.
So first step,
very simple, we're
actually just doing
that Docker build.
So initially, we're just
going to build this to latest.
Later on we'll talk
about the semantics
of actually how to build that.
But this first step will
generate a Docker container out
of our app.
So it just runs that
Docker build and stores it
in Google Container registry.
So this is all there is.
If I went and actually
ran that right now,
this would go up
to Google's servers
and actually run this build.
So that's sort of
the simple part.
As you can see here
in the name, this
is specifying what is
actually running that build.
So in our container
registry, we're
pulling down a Docker
container to actually run
that build step.
So there's a Docker
container that
runs Docker to actually
run that build for us.
So our next step
here is actually add
the Kubernetes that
will actually get built.
So this has already been
deployed to the GKE cluster.
In this example, we will just
go ahead and just refresh it.
And so we have a
web.YAML that actually
is going to use that container.
So as you can see
down here, this
is a pretty very basic web.YAML.
We're referring to an image that
the Cloud Build would actually
use.
We're specifying
environmental variables.
So this currently connects
to Cloud SQL and other things
that we're passing
to the environment--
the Cloud SQL proxy to
actually talk to Cloud SQL
so it's not out in the open.
And that's all.
It's a very simple
setup for Kubernetes.
And this is the load balancer.
And we'll talk about what this
migration file is in a second.
So in the next step, oftentimes
when you build a new package,
you might add new assets.
So that's a static
file best served
from something
like a GCS bucket.
So in this example, we can very
simply just do a gsutil copy.
So Container Builder has
been given the permissions.
So we've said, Container
Builder, you're
allowed to talk to
this particular bucket,
and you're allowed to
copy things into it.
So we don't have to do any
weird stuff to actually download
a service account onto our box.
We don't have to
worry about that.
It's all managed by Google,
by just assigning a IM rule.
And so in this example, we
would have our load balancer,
when it was presented
with public assets
that it needed to request, it
would hit this bucket instead
of going directly to the app.
And that's all that's
required for that.
So the next thing is that you
might have in a CI pipeline
is you might actually need
to migrate your database.
So in this example
with Spring Boot,
we don't actually need
to migrate a database.
It's a static app.
But in our YAML, all we're doing
is doing a echo essentially.
So what this would do if you're
using something like Rails,
this would be like a
bundle execute DB migrate.
Or if you were using any
other sort of migration tool,
you could make sure that
your Kubernetes cluster only
ran that once.
So some people like
to run the migrations
on every container that's coming
up for like a web process.
That can lead to issues
where you have contention.
So you have multiple processes
running your container.
By putting this into
a Kubernetes job,
we make sure that
his only runs once.
And what that actually
looks like in Cloud Build
is we delete the job
itself to make sure
that once it ran once
and was successful,
we have to delete it so we
can run it the second time.
And then in the second
example here, all we're doing
is running Apply and
creating that new job
and making sure that it runs.
Now, a lot of our
apps, you might
have to wait to actually
deploy and update your cluster
until your migrations are done.
In a traditional setup like
this, you'd say, OK, well,
I'm going to execute that.
How do I actually wait for that?
And that's where the
beauty of Cloud Build
comes in, where you might
say, OK, well, now I
can't just have a very
simple straightforward file.
Luckily for us, you
can extend Cloud Build
to do whatever you want.
And we have a bunch of sort
of pre-built Docker containers
that do actions for you.
So we're going to
talk about one that I
wrote called kubectl wait for.
And I thought I had it
open, but there we go.
So kubectl wait for job does
exactly what it sounds like.
It waits for a job to complete
before it lets you continue on.
So this is literally
a Bash script
that is wrapped in
a Docker file that
runs that is passed in the
argument of your job name.
So this basically
tells Cloud Build, hey,
I'm going to run this job.
But I want to wait to
actually do anything else
until this job is complete.
So just a bunch of Bash foo that
is essentially wrapping kubectl
get jobs and is just pulling
for that to actually be done.
And Cloud Build handles
all of this for you.
Once this is created
in your projects,
you can just pull that down.
And we'll show how that works.
So locally I've checked out
the Cloud Builder Community
Edition.
So for things that
are pre-built--
let's reconnect
first-- for things
that are pre-built, like
Docker, kubectl, you
can just reference that.
So those are just
complete and done.
You don't have to worry.
For things that are in the
community or things you write
yourself, you
actually need to have
a copy of that running that you
can access in your registry.
So we're going to CD into that.
So Cloud Builders Community--
helps to not put a
apostrophe first.
So we're going to CD
into kubectl wait for.
So as you see here, we
have that Bash script.
We have a Docker file.
And we have a Cloud Build file.
So what we're going to do--
I'm going to a copy from mydoc,
which I also thought I had up,
to actually go ahead and
submit to Cloud Build
to actually build
our containers.
So we have a little bit
of inception going on.
So what we're doing
here is we're saying--
X out of that--
gcloud, send up this Cloud
Build and run it for me
and store it in my registry.
So this is a Cloud Build
that you just go and grab
that's automatically going
to grab your current projects
and your current setup.
So this is actually executing.
This is going to
load up a tarball
and load that up to Google Cloud
and run that on a fresh VM.
So it loads it up.
We can view the output.
So you can see exactly
what's going on--
ran through the Docker
container, the Docker file.
And now it's done.
So now if we go over
to our registry,
we'll actually see it.
Kubectl wait for--
and here's the latest
that was just uploaded.
So now this is available
in my environment
that I can actually pull down.
Head back over.
So now that that's
there, we can go ahead
and head back into
our Pet Clinic,
once it lets me type again.
You going to let me connect?
Apologies-- network
connectivity.
We are reconnecting now.
So now that we've
uploaded that, we actually
just need to add
to our Cloud Build
to actually pull that down.
And wait for that
job is the next step.
Waiting for this to load.
Well, that's not fun.
We'll give that another second.
Let's make sure we're
using the hardwire.
Apologies.
I know you've all been enjoying
the Wi-Fi this week, so--
[LAUGHTER]
We're going to set up
a hotspot as a backup.
I did test this earlier.
So we do have a backup solution.
Cool.
It's going to take a sec.
Did everyone have fun
at the party last night?
So I never heard of The
Chainsmokers before.
I had to ask my girlfriend.
I was like, so who
are The Chainsmokers?
And then she was like, oh, they
like play the song you like.
And I'm like, cool.
And then I showed up,
and I was like, they
don't sing that song.
[LAUGHTER]
So that was fun.
I also didn't know who
DJ Spinderella was.
So I apparently
live under a rock.
OK.
Let's try another tab
because that sometimes works.
OK, cool.
Look, my Wi-Fi
hotspot came in handy.
Fantastic.
So now we're going to
head back into our app,
and we're going to
check out the next step
to remember what
step we're on now.
And this will update.
There we go, kubectl wait for.
So what this is waiting for is
for the prior job to complete.
So you see, in Cloud
Build we have these IDs?
So every step optionally can
have an ID associated with it.
So by default, Cloud Build will
just run your jobs from top
to bottom, unless you
specify that it can do things
parallely, which you
should have it do
so that things happen faster.
And in those cases,
you might still
have cases where you want to
say, hey, I want this step
to happen before this step.
But I don't really care
where in the whole file
this should actually run.
So you can put together
as-complicated-as-you-want
before this, after
this statements.
And that's what you
use these IDs for.
So like in this case, if I
wanted to, for the assets,
I could say, wait,
my public assets
only get generated when
Maven package gets run.
So I want to make sure that I
had the latest ones available.
So I could do wait
for build image.
And then instead of
running those parallely,
if I had that
enabled, I can instead
make sure that the latest
assets are actually up to date.
And that's very important
in this example.
When you have something that's
supposed to wait for something,
you actually need to have
that step to actually happen.
So you might have noticed that--
cool-- so I have this wait for.
But now I still
haven't done anything.
I still haven't
actually deployed.
So I built an image.
I've migrated my database.
I ran my tests.
That happens in
package, so that will
fail if my tests don't work.
But we still actually have to go
and update our initial manifest
with our latest image.
So in our next
step, we'll actually
just patch our manifest,
stash our changes.
And here we go.
So very simply, in use
cases where you can just
update the image and
let Kubernetes handle
taking the containers, pulling
them out, and actually updating
them, this works really well.
So we know our database
is in a good state now.
Now we need all
of our containers
to have the latest code.
So we go ahead and we patch
that manifest that's running.
And right now we're
still just going
to update that image
to just be the latest
version of Pet Clinic that we
generated in our first step.
So this is all well and good.
But at the end of
the day, you probably
don't want to have to
run Container Build
Submit every time you
run a CI/CD pipeline.
That kind of defeats
the purpose, right?
So I'm going to kick
this off, and I'll
show you guys how
to actually run this
every time your code
is actually executed.
So we had this thing
called Build Triggers--
Build Triggers.
So this is where
sort of the history--
so you can see that I
just kicked that off.
And you can see
that that's actually
running in the interface now.
So here are each of the
steps that we have so far.
And you actually can
just get the latest log.
So in addition to being
available in the interface,
you can also tail that from
the build details itself.
And if you want to
download the logs,
load them into
BigQuery or something,
you can do that
from here as well.
And you can see the images
that are actually generated.
So Build Triggers--
so a Build Trigger
is exactly what it sounds like.
It's a trigger for
running your Cloud Build.
So I have two examples here.
One is hooked up to GitHub.
So if you push your
code up to GitHub,
this will automatically
grab that and run it.
So we'll show what a Build
Trigger actually looks like.
So you can trigger it, branch,
tag, whatever you want.
You can give it some regex.
You can say, only for
something like a Java app,
maybe you only want Cloud Build
to run when one of your source
files changes, not when
you edit your README.
So that can be
pretty helpful if you
care about not doing excessive
deployments when you're just
doing cosmetic changes.
And you can
substitute variables.
So as you saw back here,
we have all these things
that are just dying.
As like a good coder, it's like,
wait, you're specifying things.
What if I want to
change that later?
That doesn't seem like
the best place for that.
So you can actually specify
things like your cluster,
your zone, other variables
from your Build Trigger itself.
So you could have a
trigger for deploying
to dev, staging, prod, and
put in your substitutes
as required.
All it is is a matter
of just putting add item
and specifying the variable.
So we'll go ahead
and let this run.
And then we'll show
how that works.
And so you can do
this on GitHub.
You can hook it up to
Bitbucket, in addition
to source repositories.
So those are the
three options you
have to actually trigger these.
Of course, you
could also, sort of,
build your own trigger by
basically just taking your code
and pushing it to a cloud
source through some other means.
And if you wanted to just
manually trigger these,
you can this a
click Run Trigger .
And here we are back
still running this.
So the other thing
to look at here
is we are currently
running this,
and we're always
building to latest.
So that's not really
a best practice.
This would mean that every
time you ran a build,
you'd be telling your Kubernetes
instances to just run that one.
And that works great in dev.
It doesn't work
that well in prod
when you want to
actually test your code
prior to having it be deployed.
So in a second, we'll actually
show how that gets updated.
I'm still in the build.
I'll just open up the next tab.
There we go.
This is actually running
through all the tests,
so it takes a second.
That tab never came
back, unfortunately.
There we go.
So in our next step, we'll
actually make that update
so that those substitute
variables can actually be used.
So we'll update in a second.
OK, so we're doing a couple
of things differently here.
One is available to
your cloud trigger
is the shortstraw of Git
Commit that is being built.
So a lot of times,
you want to be
able to specify, hey, this
build is attached to this commit
that I made.
So this is a useful way of
actually checking that out.
In addition, you probably want
to have some sort of semantic
to say what that build is
initially being used for.
So in this case,
we're going to use
something called a deploy tag.
So this would be something
like dev or prod or staging
so that you'd know, OK,
this was built, tagged
with this new update, and
this is what we're actually
going to deploy that to.
So if you need to do
a rollback, understand
the history of that build.
So we have these changes.
Some of the semantics here
are a little bit different.
So this is if it's just
a dollar sign, that
means it's provided
directly by Cloud Build.
If it's a dollar sign
followed by an underscroll,
that means you
substituted it yourself.
So essentially it's a
poor man's namespacing
between what Google
gives you when
you're building it versus
something that you define.
And you can see that
down here as well.
So now in our trigger,
we'll have something called
compute zone and cluster.
That's specified by us as
far as where we actually
want to deploy the to.
So as long as you have given
Cloud Build the permission
to the project where
that cluster's running,
this will all work.
You can see that
all the way down.
And then here, instead of
setting the image to latest,
we set it to the deploy tag
that's actually being run.
So let's head back to our
build, see if we've finished.
We failed.
We will rerun that.
Oh, it's a different one.
Here, this one succeeded.
So we'll actually go ahead
and just run our next step.
That actually includes that.
So now that we have
these changes initiated,
we can actually, in
addition to running them
through Cloud Build, you
can actually test it locally
as well.
So I'm going to grab
the substitution there.
Oh, I many not actually
have the substitution there.
So it's basically the
same as that submit.
And then we can actually
specify substitutions.
Hm, where did I put that?
So, yeah, so it's this
submit substitutions
equals, and then you
actually can specify
what you want to change.
So in our case, we have
a couple of things.
So we have a deploy tag.
So we can say deploy
tag is equal to dev.
AUDIENCE: You're missing a d.
SCOTT FEINBERG: Oh, thank you.
Spelling's hard.
It's too early in the morning.
I'm still on East Coast time.
So we have compute zone.
So we ran our zone
in us-central-c.
It's going to yell at
me for the underscroll.
And in the actual
Build Trigger, you
can actually run these yourself.
But it's pretty useful to
be able to run this locally
several times without
having to push it up,
also just being able to run your
build without having to go back
to the interface, committing
nonsense, things like that.
So it gives you the
opportunity to really play
with the build file.
And also when GitHub goes
down, you can still run it.
And what else we got?
What was the other one?
AUDIENCE: Cluster.
SCOTT FEINBERG:
Cluster, thank you.
I should have you
guys write this.
Cluster-- I think it's Scott's
Pet Clinic with an extra dash.
I spell my name with two Ts.
So I go ahead and run this.
Let's see if it lets me.
So this is going to do that
same thing-- tar up the file,
upload it, and actually run it.
So Cloud Build, at
the end of the day--
oh, cool, invalid name.
Great.
Oh, yeah.
So this shortstraw is
not available locally.
So that's why that
error happened.
So I can actually--
so while it's not
available locally,
I can actually
still substitute it.
So I can still go shortstraw
equals whatever, 1, 2, 3.
And that'll get around that.
Or I can actually look at
what my shortstraw is, which
would be the other option.
So this uploads it.
Google's actually going
to run it on a fresh VM.
And there it kicks off.
So that, in a nutshell,
is Cloud Build.
So it's very simple.
It's very straightforward.
It's excellent for these
sorts of use cases, where
you have a small app that you're
not worried about deploying.
Doing like a blue-green,
you're able to trust Kubernetes
to deploy it for you.
And hopefully you have
some sort of test suite
that is going to let you
actually accomplish CI/CD.
Other great benefits of Cloud
Build for doing these sorts
of things, especially
for small apps,
is that if you don't have
an existing CI/CD set up,
or perhaps you don't want to
spin up a new slave for Jenkins
for a new app, Cloud
Build is pay-as-you-go,
and not just in the same sense
as traditional resources.
You pay by the second that
you're build actually runs.
So I think every day you get
about 100 minutes for free
of Cloud Build.
And then you pay some number
of pennies after that.
But it's fully managed.
You don't have static hardware.
And most importantly, you're not
troubleshooting your CI/CD test
runners and slaves when
they happen to go down.
So you don't have to
actually like maintain this.
All you're maintaining is
a YAML file in your repo.
And that's Cloud Build.
If anyone has any
questions on Cloud Build
or anything like
that, we have mics
set up, if anyone has anything.
AUDIENCE: Does it help to have
an API kick it off remotely?
SCOTT FEINBERG: Yeah.
So what you're
seeing me do here,
this gcloud is just a
wrapper for an API call.
So it's all available.
As long as you have a service
account that can hit it,
you can kick it off.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SCOTT FEINBERG: No problem.
AUDIENCE: Is there anything
built in for notifications,
like updating status
in GitHub or something
like that when a build
succeeds or fails?
SCOTT FEINBERG:
It's not built in.
But there are a couple
of community projects
that essentially do that.
So you can basically add
a tag in the same way.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you trigger the
build from a local Bitbucket
repo?
SCOTT FEINBERG: Yeah.
So you can kick it off
from a local Git repo.
That's actually
what I'm doing here.
You can't run Cloud Builder
locally in that sense,
in the sense of like
Cloud Build itself is not
executing locally.
It's just easier to
just load it out.
AUDIENCE: I mean pushing to a
Bitbucket repo from Atlassian,
and then the trigger triggers
the build on Cloud Builder.
SCOTT FEINBERG: Yeah.
So that's built in.
So you actually just
have to just link it.
And then every time you
commit to Bitbucket,
it'll kick off the build.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
Scott, great talk.
Can you talk about
secret management?
And if I'm injecting
secrets into the flow,
would it actually come
up through the logs,
or there's any like--
SCOTT FEINBERG: Yeah.
So if you have actual secrets
that you want to deploy,
those should be living within
your Kubernetes secrets file.
So I can actually show
you how that works.
I have secrets in here that
are protecting the Cloud SQL
credentials.
So if you look at the
configuration here--
so it loads for a sec.
So I have these secrets.
They don't show you--
like I couldn't make
this show if I wanted to.
I would have to
download it on Base64
and code it to actually
view what these things are.
But substitutions itself do
eventually show up in the logs.
So to actually use
secrets you actually
want to have that
run on Kubernetes
and execute it there.
That's one of the reasons that,
like, running your migrations,
you should actually do that
on the Kubernetes cluster
not on Cloud Build
because you don't
want to give Cloud
Build your secrets.
And it gives you one place
to actually manage those.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Migration from other
build systems-- are there
any tools there,
or are you planning
to make any tools
that does that?
SCOTT FEINBERG: To
migrate from which system?
AUDIENCE: For other static
system, for instance,
Jenkins, Circle, whatever.
SCOTT FEINBERG:
There's not a tool
that would essentially
like do it for you,
like rewrite your pipeline.
But it's something that
if in Jenkins you're
just running a bunch
of Bash scripts,
you can execute each of those
Bash steps within Cloud Build.
AUDIENCE: Yes,
that I understand.
SCOTT FEINBERG:
You could actually
take the whole Bash script,
throw it in a Docker container,
and execute it on Cloud
Build if you wanted to.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
understand that.
I'm thinking more of the
scenarios like I'm a company,
and I have 200 repos.
It's going to be quite an effort
to migrate each in one of them.
SCOTT FEINBERG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But another
question, is there a way--
if I understand
correctly, you need
to preconfigure the pipeline.
Are you-- just a moment.
AUDIENCE: No problem.
AUDIENCE: You need to
preconfigure the pipeline
to actually does that.
Now, let's say the user wants
to change the pipeline as part
of the PR itself.
Is it possible?
SCOTT FEINBERG: Change
what on the server?
AUDIENCE: The pipeline.
Let's say you have a Jenkins
file or something like that,
God forbid.
And you actually go, and
it's part of changing.
You want to change the
CI pipeline itself,
and you want to test it
as part of the PR itself,
let's say for GitHub.
Is it possible to do the
same thing with Cloud Build?
SCOTT FEINBERG: Yeah,
so Cloud Build--
so- the YAML file is just
a part of your Git repo.
So if you wanted to experiment
with it prior to deploying,
you could do that locally.
But then if you
wanted to actually--
you could just commit, have the
cloud trigger do it as well.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
SCOTT FEINBERG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Scott.
Great talk.
Great demo.
I had a question,
just real quick ones.
Is that example
repository going to be
online or publicly exposed, and
also, the kubectl wait for job?
Just as a backward reference.
SCOTT FEINBERG: So kubectl
wait for job is public.
So if you just go to Cloud
Builders dash community,
it is right in there.
So this is sort of the--
think of it like
the Blast community
repo with a bunch of stuff.
So you have Helm
in here, Firebase,
a bunch of really good stuff.
And my sample code
will be available.
I'm not positive
which GitHub account.
Currently, it's on mine, so.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
SCOTT FEINBERG: No problem.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the demo.
So I have a few questions.
The first one, in
the UI, you were
triggering some-- you were
configuring the triggers.
Is it also available
in the YAML file
so you can do that all
declaratively in a file?
SCOTT FEINBERG: There's not yet.
I believe someone is
hopefully working on that.
But, yeah, that would be
a really nice feature.
AUDIENCE: And then for
the actual jobs, are there
any guarantees on performance?
Can we expect a similar
performance every time
we run the jobs for
our measurements?
SCOTT FEINBERG: Yeah,
so you can expect
that the job will execute
the same because it's
a fresh VM of the same size.
You can also specify
different size VMs.
So let's say that you have
something really, really beefy
and you want to run a bunch
of parallel threads in it,
you can do that.
And you can use as big as
an instance as you want.
You can just specify
that in the Cloud Build.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
And sorry, one last
question, is there a way--
if you have a lot of jobs
coming in from a lot of commits
at the same time, is there
a way to queue up and say
there's only one kind of
deploy job happening at once,
or maybe there's only one
kind of integration happening
to, like, block the
deployment from happening
during an integration test?
SCOTT FEINBERG:
Yeah, so there's no--
so you could run an integration
test in the same Cloud Build
prior to actually deploying.
So that's what that sort of
wait for example, works well.
As far as like a cross
Cloud Build orchestration,
that doesn't exist,
as far as I know.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
SCOTT FEINBERG: No problem.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Did a quick search, and it looks
like it's only for Kubernetes.
Is there plans to bring this to
like Functions or App Engine?
SCOTT FEINBERG: So you can
use Cloud Build for anything.
AUDIENCE: Oh, you can?
SCOTT FEINBERG: Yeah.
So it's like-- just think
of it like Docker containers
in the cloud.
So you could run
gcloud app deploy
for App Engine, whatever the
command is for Functions.
So you can use it for anything.
It's really for
those cases where--
like with Functions,
where you're like,
great, so I wrote
this little function.
I really don't want
to have to set up
a whole, like,
Jenkins setup just
to deploy these
six lines of code.
I can just put a
Cloud Build file.
And it'll take two seconds,
and it'll just be like--
essentially just
like the deploy step.
And that's it.
AUDIENCE: Sweet.
Thank you.
SCOTT FEINBERG: Yeah.
No problem.
Any other questions?
Awesome.
Thanks, everybody.
[MUSIC PLAYING]